it's gonna be interesting to see how the
specialist draft and everything works in
this game boat as well I mean you look
at a ruin overdrive right you know the
initiate the booze for that speed that
might be one that you want to ban for an
obj player right off the RIP but tell me
a little bit about evac to Matt maybe
well evac is an abandoned emergency
evacuation zone atop an overground
rooftop in the middle of Singapore's
flooded quarantine zone and oh you're
watching from all around the world we're
traversing the globe right now in
gameplay yeah I've never been to
Singapore I'm excited for this one yeah
this is gonna be a great game I'm gonna
mention to see how uplink plays in Black
II to it nope such a great game mode
from advanced warfare II know it's it's
a great moments in competitive play I
think it's gonna be interesting to watch
how this draft all plays out oh yeah
this will be amazing and that's it I
know we've touched on at multiple times
but when we talk about the specialist
pick when we talk about the fans it
protects their so I mean they get their
their map and game mode specific I mean
there are things that are gonna change
like the way that this is going to
change over the course of a game's
lifetime it's just absolutely phenomenal
let's kick things off your mat with -
bingo toggle gonna be the first two to
pick so I imagine teepees gonna try and
go for that ruin overdrive he's gonna
ban that mana for right off the RIP done
in buzz oh he's a tough guy
sorry buzz off gotaga though is gonna
return and ban the Annihilator for tommy
so they don't want to deal with that at
all
think about the extra armor you have is
the carrier yeah Annihilator kind of
eliminates that doesn't it right and
then you know sensor though gets hurt by
that as well I mean he's a big fan of
the Annihilator pistol on his squad you
can't use it as well be finger Tommy
he went off a little bit more than since
where they gained more than they lose
right there absolutely and then you're
gonna see key v protecting the kuda that
thing has been SLE machine man oh yeah
any time we've seen these players
getting up close and personal able to
absolutely go off with that thing such a
dangerous up-close weapon yeah then
Tommy and Buzz oh they're gonna Tommy's
gonna go for the UAV I like that no not
gonna be able to find out where they are
running the drone the counter UAV gonna
come out of buzzes so interesting two
selections there murk and since are
gonna be the last two you know maybe
they go for the profit glitch you know
and then we're gonna see the Guardian at
the hands of sensor going here is the
ante up for Merc that's gonna be
eliminating now we go to the specialist
draft this is where things get
interesting maybe I think you're gonna
see a lot more of the abilities come
into play and then maybe you know our
team water
the weapons to try and guide the way
with the drone I couldn't agree more
overdrive not supported ICP that's been
his go-to for the objective based game
he's gonna want the objective is hid in
his hand as he pushes forward for the
uplink open he's more of a sleighing
type of player and he actually goes for
reject which is a good one on this one
we seen him time time again you know
with the assault rifle play a little bit
further back and when you're trying to
control the drone let's say you drop and
it's a big part of the game you use that
water right think about it gave me at
earlier today so it's a last-second push
there trying to get forward you know
it's a tight tight game three D they
need to get one more through they two
players right or that sort that the one
player that reject up is someone in
front of them he drops his reject they
get forward they get the toss it with
what one second on the clock without
that reject that play does not get made
I think he be taking that Reaper
psychosis he's able to spawn those
drones we could do it while he has the
uplink in his hand know that finds him
two three seconds able to put it in
Tommy he's gonna go for that tempest
like we said that's the charge not
weapon that fires the electricity do you
think that has a big play here I I see
it more I guess at hard point I see it
being a pretty negative something of
this lady around Rome when you have well
how many on this map in particular on
evac you have we've seen five six people
really in around that their own spawn so
maybe he's hoping he can get a little
bit of splash names or venture with the
roux and overdrive not strong T is
really the obj player for Team TV and
then you got Merc using the gravity
spikes I would have liked that on hard
point out of Merc no able to go into the
hard points don't break that up now
going to the create a class system
alright tied 1-1 team TV team TV this
one is for all the marbles the players
are getting fired up we're ready to load
in this should be an incredible uplink
on Eve anything takes this one I'm gonna
ask you who you think you cuz you were
gonna throw me under the bus make me
pick first okay I'm okay with this I'm
going with team TP
yeah yes I am because you used to coach
him I know you're gonna pick up you
won't pick the same TV alright I expect
a big game buzz oh he's got that size
ability on the Reaper step no massive
high caliber no gun coming out of his
hands a machine gun it's gonna be really
effective alright get ready to roll here
you got a shot there of Tommy and Merc
all smiles they're feeling confident
ready to get rolling here in game number
three I won't know what Tommy has up his
sleeve with that Tempest
pick I have no idea I was trying to
think of where's I because I haven't
seen him run than the entire town
notching so that's an interesting
calling you just saved it for a game
three right well hidden teep and Merc
have been discussing strategy like oh I
mean they're saying next to each other
right now just kind of coming up with
different routes to run you see they're
gonna edit their score streaks now don't
figure out what everybody wants to run
on squad let's talk about score streaks
uh I guess what do you what do you think
would be most effective in a game like
uplink do you think with your basics you
know your hellstorm your lightning
although there's gonna be huge and yeah
those are gonna be huge I think so too I
mean especially just well really
offensively defensively I mean it's you
think of it like you would a CT Africa
to make big places people are gonna give
me the uplink has the UH the uplink the
lightning strike has that ping I mean
you're able to figure out where players
are you can call that out to the
teammates then you can decide where
you're gonna put it then game loading up
you see right there gonna be team TP
first team TV I have key V seem you have
teepees team I uh I've never been
probably we've seen uplink you know
played on this game before obviously
we've had the privilege of watch it it's
fast-paced like you see it now but I
think it takes even more teamwork right
oh you know I couldn't agree more I just
do the the pacing of it it definitely
we've seen it taking quite a bit more
team a tumor a lot more about control
let's take a look here off the RIP I'm
gonna start things off with TP now
you'll take a look at the top middle of
the screen really right under the tying
it says a way basically showing and that
one's gonna have the draw another hand
soon as TP picks that up it's gonna now
show TP so just get the eye on there
you'll be able to see who's gonna be
carrying it he also remember he has
overdrive he doesn't have it up yet he's
gonna be taken up pretty much
immediately going to be dropped there
it's gonna move for we're gonna see
sensor getting his hands on the drone
here early but he's gonna have to be
careful when he uses that overdrive
right I mean you get dropped so fast
with the drone if you use it just single
handily he's he's sensor he's gonna bait
players huh with that drone well he's
got he's got over driver
since which is an absolutely crushed
that player you see how fast he's going
goes over one way right off the RIP that
Dustin dug sensor Martin peace and love
able to beam up huge there you got you
got gotaga was three Adama to switch
over to buzz oh he's for no right now
he's ready to get going you can see he
chose a weapon in this one gonna end up
dropping their flexy struggling it oh
and three I'm gonna go to me sorry big
it oh and four will switch to Tommy on
team TV they're trailing by one member
this game for all the marbles gonna be
our final game tied 1-1 and Tommy has
that Tempest tried to get a shock wasn't
able to and it's gotta get charged up to
see gotaga trying to get in uses the
reject with the drone in hand able to
put in a two-point play so you see the
use of the specialist abilities able to
help their teams put in those points and
it's gonna be now going to censor he's
just going to toss it out get guns up
not able to win that one is Tommy comes
flying in everyone vying for control
right now
closest fan of the action going to be
the French sensation gotaga
he's set up here you can see he's got
his specialist ready as TV he's sensor
different since we're gonna push off the
map you can see he's gonna use that
regen ability trying around pick up TP
as tepees trying to make it away with
the drone he's gonna get shut down I
want to jump on the board of buzzer wait
does he still have his specialist no he
actually used it so he's gonna be
running the Reapers specials with this
same that robot arm that transforms into
a higher but they still have a 3o
advantage here I want to see if buzzer
can get that minigun and they can kind
of take TTP and put them in a spawn trap
if he's able to just lock down those
lanes go for some easy points that you
could rally they look fuzzles able to go
big with that there it is hip fires
through zone drugs basically see with
the x-ray vision here as he's running
away yeah we can see what he's gonna be
pushing right now you can see currently
thrown us away everyone is really vying
for control right now they're getting
four trying to get eyes on the next
minute it's gonna be Merc Merc set up on
top of his it's not here Mike
murk I want to see if these designs they
using any sky you can see basically that
carrier right below man they put so I
was trying to see if he was gonna use it
at the same time they fired through
another dog so they're gonna have a
five-oh advantage really team TV running
away with this one after getting beat up
and that gave one heart point and no
teep struggling right now four and
eleven ghana get going in the obj
department see merck able to get a care
package so we stay on with him to see
what he decides to do whether he's got
gonna use that care package through the
response gonna call it and see what he
gets with it
we'll keep eyes on here if it's gonna be
dropping in under two minutes to go in
this one he's still got his lifts up as
well TP though is gonna have drone his
hands i just want to see what he's
getting and they'll switch over to TP or
carrier he's got a UAV now gonna help TP
know where the opponents are as he's
trying to score this for his team you
see he's gonna use this area to wall run
he's gonna quit that overdrive at the
right time too much overdrive yeah -
you've got a little bit too excited
there he's like I am gonna make a huge
play everyone's gonna go crazy and then
now I just jumped over the back Reggie's
the laughter not able to pick it up he's
gonna be down sensor is able to grab it
can he get it gonna toss it off here and
they've they've still got this 500 lead
unfortunately what was gonna be a sick
play from Stevie I was gonna say comes
up a little short so it the opposite of
that actually over jumps you know the
satellite scoring area it's gonna be
sensor with overdrive ready see what
needs doing he's gonna create the
story's gonna get one then he gets
killed by Tommy's tempest you see it
show kooky Tommy able to take out to
layer in the middle we said how he was
gonna use that was able to pick up a
couple they're switching over to TP he's
gonna grab it for just a second for he
falls he's double head- right now at 8
and 16 not having the best game three
but I inspect the veteran to step it up
we got 30 seconds here left on the first
side who's able to pick it up it's good
at fault at Tommy
how can Tommy get for it instead of
resetting he's inside Iraq he's gonna go
for that same route that tee abuse it's
such a great round I mean you can get
that height while wall running and then
you're able to just jump in will that
score even you're able to throw it off
the wall here it's Tommy's gonna go for
a - yeah
oh so team TV gonna get on the board
here with ten seconds left and I think
it was good target they gotta kill just
a second too late it's away with five
seconds I don't think anyone's in a
position really to fire one last one
through last second gonna tick off the
clock and five two this could very
easily be five four though if it wasn't
for TP jumping out of the stadium yeah
then uplink we're gonna switch sides
gonna play another realm
obviously scores will accumulate it's
gonna be very interesting to see if
teams he be coming to come back holy
down three obviously not remotely out of
this over the past day or so we've seen
some ridiculous comebacks here and again
if it wasn't for one mishap this would
basically be a tie game right now who do
you want to start off on side two I know
we do see flexes gone as absolutely
crushing Raymond haven't give him enough
love one of the best players all France
we've known for his really high
sensitivity right we see gotaga make
some amazing place it'll pick off
weren't right out the rib it gets one
from with the conifers second is now
gonna be back to censor I got him
highlighted on your mini-map we're gonna
see him trying to get for going to the
north side go Thomas me the one leading
the way so gonna stay with him just a
second it's he's basically his cover is
there trying to get both he's gonna drop
I'll kick a day later and sir he's young
you're drunk there comes the speed tried
to fly Sean just as he gets sacked and
Tommy hits him with that Tempest since
are able to get it off right in the nick
of time big play right there at a sensor
he's been doing some great work in the
obj Department yeah some of these shots
he had at first what do you have with
overdrive and I got that off of what
half a second to go really before he
felt they have a four-point advantage
right now sticking with him just for a
second through the reason I'm actually
gonna go over to buzz OH is buzz OH is
currently on a force and he's melting
he's got sites set up not even looking
at the second as he pushed him how dead
great when you have a spawn trap set up
right so Buzzle wants to keep that hand
so like he had a four did they know
exactly where the other team spawning he
pops that specialist ability he's
probably able to get to three players
coming on spawn couldn't agree more Matt
we've got Tommy though you can see there
it's also a really pointed out but it
kind of underneath reticle you can see
his armor a show getting forty as full
armor gonna be taken out almost
instantly must have had a couple players
shooting him it's gonna drop the sensor
sensors got it they don't want to throw
it out they're gonna wrap you saw this
work effectively earlier the same do I
go
leading the way since they're gonna be
your carrier they're trying to get
forward let's see if we can get some
more magic here out of Doug sensor
Martin again buzzes oh they're with him
he's gonna win a gun plant verse TVC go
talk is gonna try and lead the way you
see Center go from Waldo that time not a
really connect with that throw but he
has his overdrive so next time he has
the job building something happen let's
stay on with Merc he's got that gravity
spikes and want to see when he decides
to use it three minutes left on the
clock
they're trailing by four Merc and TP the
veteran players have gotta come up
clutch here you see TP giving one a 17
and 23 trying to climb back in it but it
is gonna be buzz oh that currently has
the drone and he's got home free for the
most part you can see they're spawning
at the bottom of the map he's trying to
get forward if they just execute this
quickly he should have a one-point toss
shots coming in and he's gonna get
dropped right outside no one else there
to pick it up this should be a toss out
by Merc I think he's been on reset to D
but this time he's gonna get forward and
she's gonna TP into T because t p-- has
more of that obj set up with that
overdrive ability American to try and
clear the way with the gravity spikes I
think they're gonna try and bait people
into this room for Merc try and make a
play here that you have Tommy with The
Tempest set up right outside and dad is
not gonna work he's gonna try booster
work not gonna be able to fly through a
wall of players there it's gonna fall -
buzzer buzzes got it in hand and he's
gonna wrap we saw a similar play from
sensoring photographer Lee er yeah
yourself us hope before you probably had
an easy score just didn't bring it up
the mat unit obviously a lot easier for
us to say we have x-ray know well
wouldn't you rather have somebody like
you really get that diversity of who's a
slayer who's an obj player yeah you know
you pass it to the players who have
those obj abilities let buzz' use that
minigun to clear the way and it really
just defines roles that much better than
specialists since we're getting bored
they're starting to pull away here 7 2 2
and then you saw the reject there's even
a pop back up provides a bit of a
distraction but not able to get it
through do they have any one there to
get it it was good time able to fire it
through with the dunk I don't think they
attain it
when sensor had the drone gotaga uses
reject and that smoke came up as soon as
the smoke came up you saw sensor pop his
overdrive and then trying to use the
flute you know the smoke from gotaga
coming back to fight in front of them
back to life distraction right yeah oh
well here they are getting forward in
again you can see they really been
enjoying this north side of the map is
they're coming for candy make that Chuck
gets cut down is there anybody else
there maybe the position to make the
play chibi was there for a second
guitarist coming from behind Buzzo was
there
he felt katana might have a chance
there's two kitties a huge kill fuse
able to get a free dog if he wins that
one but honestly at this point 45
seconds on the clock TV BJP has to do
something massive here they're gonna
make this comeback and if you're gotaga
you don't even need the drone is this
more time maybe 30 seconds left you have
reject you can just stay right on the
drone spawn and come back to life fight
a second time have enough by now but it
seems like they're gonna go for another
and how many times have you seen this
kind of grabbing drone instead of
pushing forward they're wrapping back
they've been going wrapping around the
back and taking the north side I didn't
really see that in the players they
first started playing the map already
starting to develop in here the toss
goes way off to the right not able to
sink that one clock is ticking away this
is team ki B's game there is no amount
of miracles that can bring back TP have
you seen Peavy go massive scene with
gotaga since they're doing a new job in
the obj Department C gotaga picking up
one here he's just trying to pad his
stats a little bit
fuzzums been so consistent all day long
team kV wins this one we
um with TV you tried to take that
prediction away from me you've got your
slide going by really you I really need
your baited me into it and they're so
good the game one respond they
disappeared